sorry dude that's the first hammer dude
what $1 not wearing a helmet this guy is
that my new Christmas clothes yeah my
new Christmas shirt my new Christmas
pants my new Christmas shoes fine engine
a new Christmas clothes you can do that
did you guys all see rug one when you
watch bro one how do you feel honestly I
was a little disappointed because
everyone dies I was kind of hoping
they'd do something a little bit more
interesting than that
I walked out of going that was a very
pretty film those V effects were awesome
and that's kind of where it ends because
you're like but there's nothing that
really sticks with you we can just be
all the big advances around here how
would you make it better sours these
big-budget movies they try to be perfect
in every single way they drop from a
language of other movies what you get is
this basically this giant big recycled
version of a film that kind of touches
upon all the tiny little things of
things things you've already seen and
felt before it checks all your boxes for
what a story needs but it doesn't give
you the same take away here's the thing
about wrote one main character Jen I
can't name a single hard decision she
makes an entire film
she's a main character that loses her
agency it's considered bad writing to
have a character a main character that
is passive what that means is that the
character sits there and everybody else
tells that character what to do
everybody else pushes that character
through the plot every else push that
character the story the characters low
along for the ride persons Jim didn't
have a goal she was just sat there and
every else told her what to do the best
example of this is at the very end when
you're getting those hard drives
Jim stands by the side a freaking Cassie
in her air his name is is the man
operating the hard drive machine
why isn't Jim doing it she's the main
character this week character kind of on
a roller coaster throughout the whole
thing that's a huge byproduct of the
fact that these movies are constructed
completely independent of the characters
when you plan these movies out to a tee
where you know these scenes are going to
happen blah blah it's like the
characters don't even matter anymore
you're just writing the plot
you're forcing these characters to just
ride along with these decisions you've
made it's not interesting you want to
part with Darth Vader at the end killing
guys was so thrilling it's not because
you get to see Darth Vader kill guys
seeing Darth Vader wants something and
actively go and try and take it and
something all his power comes out like
holy [ __ ] this guy's a huge badass I
didn't know he was so scary as the
characters being active he's going and
he's making hard decisions he's killing
people to get his goals he has
intentions and he has obstacles I love
that thing thanks Aaron Sorkin what do
you think of a pun Ben every movie has
to like feed into the next movie
nowadays and all the characters have to
be around for all the sequels and I was
just so happy that this movie was like
[ __ ] it
where does everyone's dead they didn't
care and they weren't trying to like set
it up for a sequel they were just like
this is what we're gonna do Ben there's
six more movies that came after this one
what's terrible about it is that you
kind of go like from the outset the
assumption is these characters aren't
going to be that memorable because this
is it this is all you happen for so it's
like you don't get to build characters
that are like damn like I'm gonna
cosplay as this one character that said
there's a couple things that road one
did correctly one there were no Jedi in
a movie second thing that they did that
is really well acknowledging what most
people said is a giant plot hole in Star
Wars which is why can you blow up a
Death Star with the simple proton
torpedo in a exhaust shaft making it a
character based crisis of conscience
such a good way to approach that and is
so compelling and this is also all just
completely ignoring the fact that it is
a very beautiful film the effects are
like some of the best and out there on
the market right now it's like yeah but
that's going to be expected from
and Disney films enslavers it's also
just like beautifully polished just like
alright in the trailer there's a shot
where Jin is running to I think it's
like the little platforms like recenter
the satellite dish and a TIE fighter
rise up and cuts her off that shot was
actually added by the trailer house they
like the shots cool we need to jazz it
up and they added the TIE fighter
themselves probably with that one in 3d
so in a nutshell if you want to make a
better Star Wars movie let your
characters be active don't make them
passive don't worry about plot holes
like studios are so concerned with
people picking apart the movies on
reddit that's fine we can do that just
make a character that has derive any
motion and ambition and the ions to be
along for the ride I mean that's why
we've Skywalker and Han Solo and
Princess Leia are so compelling even in
a sci-fi universe all this crazy world
building make them character based with
the schema drama from people my riches
are a balance train
you never seen finding the cube that
skateboarding movie yeah it's got a
Christian Slater in it Tony Hawk is
rodney mullen I was three years old in
this film came out right what is leading
no basically it's a it's a giant crystal
cube gleaming it basically like you're
taking 409 or a little bit you're
believing it
gleaming no you don't stand on you blame
it what's the cue I have to do you gleam
it
what's the quickly and gleaming the cube
is self-explanatory skate on it
how's the skateboard turn this [ __ ]
skate on lean the cube you didn't care
for the direction the world was heading
did you see that petition go to
potentially actually no there was it
it's a good addition there's a
change.org petition for event that shave
his mustache so people will hate then
people hate winter this is what it is
just kidding it's 2017 oh I feel that
way we good